les temps changent et les mesures contre
le gaspillage devienne une mode voire
même un business model
c'est le cas de cette entreprise de
réparation un atelier spécialisé dans la
maintenance de locomotive nous emmenons
à saint pierre des corps près de tours
le noeud ferroviaire de saint pierre des
corps
juste à côté un atelier de 4000 m²
flambant neuf un atelier de réparation
de locomotives où travaillent
actuellement 26 personnes
on entretient des engins ferroviaires et
ont fait de la maintenance de la petite
maintenant ce qu'on appelle latine
maintenance jusqu'à la maintenance
lourde à savoir ça va de une journée
maintenance préventive mais on fait
aussi du correctif qui peut durer
jusqu'à 16 semaines les locomotives
réparé dans cet atelier servent à tirer
des wagons de marchandises ou à
effectuer des travaux de voie un marché
très important pour cette société
aujourd'hui on est un concessionnaire on
est adossé à un constructeur qui
s'appelle vosloo qui est qui est un
constructeur allemand qui fabrique des
machines de fret pour le marché européen
et aujourd'hui on représente vosloo pour
la france on peut aussi on sait et on se
développe dans ce sens là on se
développe pour pouvoir intégrer dans nos
ateliers les compétences et recevoir des
machines d'autres marques actuellement
l'atelier réparé environ cinq
locomotives et envisage de passer à 14
en simultané des locomotives qui
nécessite beaucoup d'entretien celle là
ce qu'on va faire c'est une remise en
état donc ça veut dire pour faire
quasiment une remise en service comme si
elles sortaient du sinn parce que comme
l a pas tourné pendant un an
donc on doit tout contrôler aussi bien
moteur aussi bien l'attraction enfin
tous les équipements on doit les deux
nouveaux l'hérault contrôler pour
s'assurer du bon fonctionnement
par exemple les cuves de gasoil il va
falloir les traiter parce que comme ça
fait longtemps qu'elles sont inactives
sap a tourné l'atelier tourangeau
fraîchement inauguré espère déjà passé
l'an prochain de 28 à 40 salariés
[Musique]
qu'ils soient trop vieux à votre goût au
cassé certains objets ont encore de la
valeur notamment après être passé entre
les mains de ces réparateurs bénévoles
puisque nous sommes au sein d'un hyper
qu'a fait jean pierre qu'est ce qu'un
hyper café qu'elle est ce concept hyper
café c'est un concept qui existe depuis
une quinzaine d'années qui a été
inventée amsterdam
c'est un endroit où vous venez avec un
objet qui vous appartient si un peu
d'attentes on vous offre le café avec un
petit gâteau depuis dès que un
réparateur se libère vous mettez en face
de nuit et vous l'aurez pareil avec lui
qui est important c'est vraiment avec la
personne vous donner une deuxième vie à
des objets finalement une fois sur deux
beaucoup ça fait des années qu'on existe
ici en tout cas à saint-jean-de-braye on
est vingt cinq bénévoles et ça a été
facile à trouver les bénévoles
relativement facile justement parce que
c'est dans l'air du temps
on veut doivent tous sculptés presque
tous lutter sur l'obsolescence contre
l'obsolescence programmée
on veut éviter d'acheter un objet qui
est réparable pour éviter de le faire
fabriquer à l'autre bout du monde pour
voilà donc là il ya vraiment un
engouement c'est pour ça qu'il est
rippert café dans le mondial à 2000 dans
le monde où un grand secret et se
développe vraiment il y en a
régulièrement dans notre pays qui se
créent et l'objectif qui dément sur un
territoire comme le nôtre c'est qu'il ya
un super café à côté de chacun d'entre
nous est ce que les réparations sont
voués à finalement aller sur le marché 2
casio c'est vraiment personnel alors
normalement c'est un objet personnel
celui qui viendrait avec un objet pour
ensuite je vais le réparer je vais leur
revendre sur un site d'annoncés si on
comprenait ça on refuserait donc ce
n'est pas du tout pour faire du commerce
d'ailleurs nous ont fait pas du commerce
on n'a aucun rapport avec l'argent si
quelqu'un veut donner une petite pièce
parce qu'il est content bien sûr on
accepte c'est pour acheter du café pour
acheter quelques outils tels que petites
pièces détachées voilà mais il n'y a
aucune obligation c'est effectivement
gratuit
s'il ya beaucoup de personnes donnent
c'est très étonnant beaucoup de
personnes donnent presque plus qu'il le
faudrait il le donne parce qu'ils se
sentent pris en charge avec sourire et
efficacité donc effectivement ça marche
très bien avec très très très peu
d'argent il ya très peu de raptor d'âge
on n'est pas dans le monde économique
un rippeur café n'est pas en concurrence
avec ceux qui gagnent leur vie en
réparant des objets c'est plutôt au
contraire pour essayer de réparer les
objets que le ce que le que le le
système économique classique ne peut pas
réparer parce que l'économiquement c'est
pas viable en décalage est une société
du tout jetable de l'obsolescence
programmée les rippeurs café sont un
lieu d échanges de savoir-faire de
convivialité mais également un lieu où
on peut réparer des objets qui étaient
vouées à la poubelle